starting pitcher tonight for the giants
will be the right-hander logan webb webb
23 years of age so we're about ready for
the first pitch as chu stands in
first pitch of the game is swung on and
lifted in the air to left field that
sends hunter pence back at the track
looking up that ball out of here
a leadoff home run for shinsu chu on the
first pitch of the ball game and the
rangers on top one nothing so the
rangers with a man on still nobody out
here in the top of the first inning
on the ground could be a pair
dubon with a throw to first digging it
out as flores two down
this is hit up the middle
and solano will make the play and
they'll end the inning left-hander mike
miner in his ninth year at the big
league level six four 210 pounder
swing and a miss and flores strikes out
first pitch he swings and rips one to
short played by elvis on a short hop he
drops to a slide throws to first in time
what a play by elvis andrews taking a
hit away and probably keeping a run off
the board here's robinson torinos
catcher batting from the right side
gonna miss he got him good change up now
the runner goes what ain't gonna miss he
struck him out to end the inning two
hits two left a lot of pitches thrown so
here's darren ruff with an rbi
opportunity
shoots this one to right gallows coming
in he can't get to it it falls in for a
hit and this game is tied
way off the plate from the right side he
bounces one to third kinder fluff has
got it to second for one o'tore on the
first frazier receives it scooping it up
and it's a double play so here's gallow
with a man on
gallow rips one down the right field
line that's a fair ball heading towards
the corner oh door hits the bag at
second it's fumbled by slater on the
track oh dora racing around third of the
plate the relay throw not in time and
the rangers reclaim the lead they're now
up two to one
shot on the ground hits sharply to dubai
and that'll end the inning so calhoun
hit it right on the nose so the giant's
going to the bullpen to get the lefty
connor minez who comes in at a very high
pressure spot against the rangers third
place hitter with the bases loaded
popped him up on the first pitch
somebody call for it
somebody call for it and finally flores
calls for it well nice job connor minez
on one pitch he gets odor mike
yostremski to lead things off
high fly ball into deep right center
field gallow on the move gallows going
to try to grab it it bounces up and over
the wall and it robs you strimski of a
triple
hunter pence
and hits this one on the ground
shortstop andrew's right there one away
does move
to third
strike pitch to longoria a little tapper
back toward the mound perfect play for
miner able to hold yasrimski at third
1-1
there's a swing of the ball lifted in
the air to short left center elvis
backing up on it with his mask on the
shortstop backs up makes the play and
minor gets out of a jam after giving up
a lead off double here's trump now his
next hit will be his first hit in his
big league career
on the ground in his first big league
hit is a single to right field
so they'll get that baseball for
chadwick trump
two down the giants need the clutch two
odd hit here if they're going to get
anybody home florence it's a high fly
ball to left chew is back at the wall
out of here
and it's off the plate in and he goes
down and stays inside it and just golfs
it out of here that's a three run home
run and the giants take the lead one two
that strike three called in the inning
is over here's trump picked up his first
big league hit in the fifth inning line
drive down the left field line that's a
fair ball and on the move is rough
and they're going to wave in rough
here's the relay from andrews it is not
in time giants have a 5-2 lead up the
middle and a base hit and here comes
trump he's going to score on dubon's
base hit
swing and a miss he strikes out slater
in jabot nice job here in the sixth
inning luke farrell the new pitcher now
for the texas rangers giants have met at
the corners with two outs for donovan
solano solano with a base hit and that's
gonna knock in wilmer flores and it's
now seven to two
ruff drives it into right center field
on the move is solac still on the move
he dives and it's in and out of his
glove
one run scores
solano scores rough with a double and
the giants have just broken it open
chorinos at third ref snyder at first
and here comes rooned odor
got him and that's the ball game
so the giants open up this series with a
nice win lots of offense
logan webb pitched well the bullpen was
fabulous